how are you good you know how to light
up a room that's very nice thanks for
being here
thank you it's very nice oh thanks for
being here you know we actually haven't
talked since
since friends uh went off the air and
it's so strange because it's been 18
months
i don't know how you feel that does not
feel it doesn't feel like friends has
been off the air for 18 months because
it's
it's still on all the time well so it's
really not off the air
exactly yeah it's still going and going
strong do you sorry
yeah it's okay no people i mean people
watch it people still love it i think
they're going to be watching that show
for a long time it's going to be like
the honeymooners it'll be on for a long
time
yeah yeah they're going to start showing
it in black and white for no reason and
do you find yourself like passing tvs
every now and then and the show is on
and do you do you ever watch it i do
yeah every once in a while if i'm
flipping through the channels and i see
it i do
stop and watch it it makes me happy oh
that's nice
that's really nice it does i miss it you
know what's funny is that when enough
time goes by you won't this is true you
won't remember what happens in an
episode oh that's true so i'll get to
watch it sort of like you all did
yeah yeah and you'd be like oh what's
going to happen you know that's and
who's she
yeah that's me you know lisa kudrow was
here and she said when the show went off
the air
people were talking about grabbing
different stuff and she grabbed the
cookie jar
from the set that had the little clock
on it and i'm curious did you grab
anything
i didn't grab anything did i grab
anything
no i didn't grab anything they all stole
stuff right yeah
yeah yeah people say like oh i think i
took this i took that that's called
stealing
really that's wrong but they felt like
10 years i own this yeah
yeah yeah like matt leblanc said he took
like a whole sectional or something from
that you know
didn't he take the foosball table i
think he said he was going to take it
but they stopped him when he was going
through the game
yeah he's just like you can't have that
now it's funny this is a homecoming for
you you're from new york city you were
you were raised here i was raised here
92nd in columbus
that's nice
now you can give that a dress out yeah
now i can give that a dress out no but
uh but you had a good time it's such a
it's such a cool place to grow up i
would think there's a lot of excitement
such a great place it's so beautiful
just you know people on the streets all
walks of life i i miss that
i do miss that because you know la
you're getting a little bubble right
you travel in the bubble to your next
that's your choice to travel in a little
bubble
[Laughter]
it's the new bubble it's what everyone's
doing did you
do you uh i heard a story that you once
slept outside of a hotel
here in new york city why did you do
that the omni berkshire hotel
uh because i was um i was uh having a
i was a duran durani i was a durani fan
and
they were doing the uh saturday night
live and they were the musical guest and
you know they say
tonight's guests for you know whatever
are staying at the omni berkshire hotel
no they're not
and i uh i with my girlfriends
went out with a rose and waited for them
to come home
and they never came home and so we
stayed out there all night and this is
asleep on the street that's a little
pathetic right right
i do that i sleep on the street you do
when mr t is in town and i know where
he's staying
you do uh no i i i understand though
that level of intensity about you know i
really want to meet this person
it's really weird of me i have to say
it's this little strange phase
but one thing that's nice is then you go
on and become a big star you could me
have you ever met
the people i met uh simon labon oh you
did
yeah i think we i scared him what
happened well i was with a friend of
mine in
uh a a store in santa monica
and my friend saw him and just basically
grabbed him and said don't move you just
stay right here don't move and
brandon got me and was like jen you've
got to come here you've got to see this
you've got to see this so i think i'm
going to see something
not someone right and he basically
throws me and i just
i hope i just i couldn't believe it
right i told him i said i slept out in
front of a hotel for you
he didn't say a word i mean he literally
didn't speak i think we just scared him
and he didn't
say anything but were you were you were
you known or were you famous jennifer
aniston then so i can't believe he
didn't say oh my god that's so i mean
you know he just sort of slowly looked
at me like i was nuts and grabbed my
hand and shook it and then i we were
it was a very awkward moment i don't
really remember it truthfully yeah
yeah i think you blacked out i think
that's what happened
yeah and you had a traumatic experience
here in new york city involving santa
claus
santa slapped me what i was noticing
this is good
it was a homeless guy with wearing a
santa's hat right
and i was walking down broadway after a
dance class and i was with my girlfriend
and i
basically saw this guy standing in the
middle of the street and i just happened
to be passing him right at the time that
he just went
oh my god and backhanded me right really
hard yeah
and uh i was stunned and i was like what
the hell are you doing and
nobody stopped and i don't know what you
expect people to do like go beat up
the homeless santa but but they you know
yes you have something but there was
like no you know
see that's new york people are just like
yeah girl got hit by santa let's go
you know so yeah that's fun growing up
in new york
yeah these are heart moving stories
now let's talk about let's talk about
derailed because i got to see this movie
last night
and i really liked it and i don't it's
it's a very difficult movie to talk
about because you can
give things some things away so i'm not
going to do that it's a suspenseful
thriller with lots
of twists exhibit is in this movie he's
one of your co-stars and he was on the
show the other day
and he said it was hard for him because
the first day on the set
literally the first thing he had to do
as part of his character was grab you
and put a gun to your head
and sort of throw you around and he said
he was freaked out yeah he just really
didn't want to do that to you
he really didn't and he was he was so
sweet he just kept apologizing and are
you okay are you okay to the point where
i was like you really just gotta throw
me down
right just don't i mean i'm okay i'll
let you know if it hurts
right now right i could see
moving on back to santa
it's them it's not us uh just sounds
dirty people um you're working with uh
this is a swedish director swedish as
vedic swedish director
uh what did you learn any uh any cool
you know swedish terms
yeah he did teach us a couple it's hard
to remember the the swedish language
right but uh people remember the case
remember the hee the heart the who the
people
they remember the kings exactly right
and he doesn't really talk like that at
all actually that's not really the way
they talk
but um i like my stereotypes
irish people are like it's just much
simpler that way
yeah no he's you know i don't know it's
a canoe
canoodle there's certain words that you
just start to you i don't care noodle is
a swedish word
isn't it canoe noodle but you know then
you start using it for anything like
don't you get canoodly with me
well it's funny they also use it in the
uh in the tabloids all the time they're
always talking about celebrities canoe
we're seeing canoodling in a bar yes and
i think it you know it's such a
it's such a weird term it's a good word
though it's like they're just like
making pasta together or something
my mom and this is true if two people
are
you know getting busy she calls it
playing paddy fingers
oh she's like oh i heard he was playing
patty fingers with her and i'm like what
are you talking about
they get together and go the dumbest
thing in the world uh
sounds strange she's a strange woman